all right johnny dollar
johnny uh where are you from where'd you
go out well i grew up in a place called
illinois
uh alton where are you based now
minnesota minneapolis yes sir okay
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents as a kid uh well i had
my mom you know she was uh
she was she raised us both seven kids
how would you describe your childhood it
was great
i had everything i might have wanted
dad was out of the picture excuse me
your dad was not part of your life
no not really not really i've seen him
you know he bought me a
little stuff when i was young you know
but he really wasn't there
[Music]
so you're introduced to the game at what
age 16
16. how'd that go down i
moved to a place called michigan and i
met a girl you understand she was 28
years old
and i was 16 years old and she really
liked what was going on
how did things start well we fooled
around for a couple of years you know
and you know she uh she was a veteran
she was really really seasoned you know
what i mean
and uh she paid me a little money you
know bought me a few outfits bought me a
car and things you know she really
really wanted to mess with me
you know so that's how that went
and i took it from there to new york
city
and how many girls would you have at
once i've been four or five deep
or five and you're still active today
absolutely
so what does a pimp provide to the girls
you're providing
protection you're managing their money
no i
i provide knowledge that's gonna carry
them through the lifetime you know
after i'm dead and gone the knowledge
that uh they've received off of me by
being around me
uh it carries them on through
they really get a lot of ism
and what what does a girl get out of it
oh they have everything just like i have
they they get
they have diamond rings lime jeans and
silk suits and lizard boots they have it
just like i do
i don't want to see mine no other than
me
i want when they see my girls i want
them to see them shop where they say you
know
it represents me and it says a lot
and the money they make they give to you
absolutely
but now i i give i i give just like i
receive
i take care of them i make sure they
have cars their hair did
you know shoes and you know all the
things that they need i can
kind of like guide them to stay out of
trouble you know to deal with the right
people
the upper scale people i try to keep
about to
you know the bad part of the game
that's where your your expertise comes
in excuse me your expertise
yes yes yeah have you ever done prison
time
yeah i've been a president before what
was that for pimping a pattern in san
diego
and your girls are uh what races oh
races
they come going you know all flavors i'm
not prejudiced or racist
i like them all you know as long as they
pay it
they they can they could do a little
land and you have sex with your girls
sometimes sometimes what about drugs
they deserve it when they deserve
and what about drugs well i don't
i like weed and i drink champagne you
dig that's all i want
as a woman to follow my feet anything
else is no good
it'll bring me down
but now there's some out there that do
do it but they don't last with me
[Music]
what is your style you know there's
there's many different ways of
of uh pimps have many different styles
yes some use intimidation i'm gonna
finesse pimp
and really i just don't you know i
really don't like using that word pimp
you know because i don't really pick up
normal
but you know i got a lot of females that
helps me you know
i was kind of like smart and sharp in
the game you know i took all my whole
dollars and i invested in a limousine
company
now i own my own limousine company you
know i don't have to
you know wait on my bus to come in and
say the trick ran off with
the money or i went to sleep he didn't
pay me you know the buses they're going
to come in with that money and the
limo's going to come in with it
you know but i have a lot of female to
help me too and what's
what's more important to you love or
money money is more important than me
money is the root of all evil
and i i love money you know i know what
to do with it
and that's what a lot of people admire
me for because i know how to invest my
money in the right places
you know and that's a good thing in life
what i learned off
an older guy i always raised by the
older guys you understand because
and they're dead and gone now not gonna
would rest in peace
but i take part of their game and i take
part of this other game
you know that they didn't taught me and
i mix it up you know what i mean
and it lasts a lifetime i'll be 60 years
old friday
and that's a blessing to be at that age
but i have
one i have so much knowledge i have 80
year old knowledge
because all my people that i was turned
out
by that you know gave me gain yeah
they're dead and gone you know but they
gained carry on
and i have so many females across this
united states
that i've showed the game to and they're
still living right now and they're
making money they have their own homes
cribs and everything
i'm not with them now but you know they
advance and that's what
i i can't be mad and that's what they do
once they branch off me they keep on
getting money but they manage their own
money
and they kind of like that it's kind of
hard for me to get it now but i just
don't get the blessing that i've taught
them i'll show
them and they're able to make it work
right now they raise their kids they do
it all
that's good i've heard from a lot of the
girls and and
and attempts that uh sometimes there's a
little more than just sex for money
sometimes there's
trying to figure out ways to get a watch
or some money out of the guy's wallet
that he may
have you know from the trick that's for
them other guys i mean you know i don't
really condone on them you know the
thieves you know i mean
but in the game it do happen you have
thieves you know they come into your
life yeah but that's a lot of condone on
that
i have my girls i focus i have i make
them focus
on catching sugar daddies and then money
so there's a whole lot of them you know
so they have like three different sugar
daddies where they can see
twice a week you know three times a week
and they ain't giving them no change
they're giving a real paper you dig
yeah stacks on top of stacks it's more
like i
have them be they it's like their
girlfriend that's what they think is
their girlfriend you know
something like that and i just keep it
like that you know i'm not no jealous
person
[Music]
wait what kind of girls do you look for
i look for the honest ones the ones
that's loyal
you know you got to mess with the girl
to like you not the one you like
the one you like that you're gonna hear
[ __ ] you uh uh
hell no maybe later but the one that
like you you'll never hear them say no
it's ease more easier to function and
operate with them
what's the longest one of your girls has
been with you i always get a five or ten
seven eight nine year run out of them
that's great i've got one now i've had a
30 year run out of
wow what is the basis of the pimp and
prostitute relationship is it
she needs to like you she needs to find
you attractive she's got to like you
and when they give you your money when
they give you their money you know they
like you
when they help you and listen to you be
there for your time eight or the sins
you know they like you that's the ones
you keep on your side
they don't like you they when they come
time for the
uh a touchdown they're not they're not
they're gonna fumble the ball
yeah nobody can uh duplicate my style
and my swag been around for a long long
time
all over the country i go way back with
every pimp you might know
i know every pimp in the country and my
name is impeccable
you mentioned pimp johnny dollar they're
gonna say that's a good guy that's my
man
it'll never be no dirt
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life the most important
lesson i've learned
mess with the chick that like you not
the one you like the one you like you're
gonna accept
all kinds of stuff out of it and y'all
know it's true
you're gonna accept all kinds of stuff
but you never stepped off another chick
and it might be another chick right next
door that like you
and gonna do everything and keep you
right but uh
you'd rather mess with this pretty girl
over here that's giving you all kind of
problems you did
that's how the world goes not just with
the pip in the whole game
a lot of people have a tendency the
right people they're supposed to treat
right
that's loyal and dedicated they overlook
it and they treat the other people right
that mean i'm no good no intentions
and that's life but you know i i have to
mess with the right girls you know
you've been doing this a long time i'm
sure you've seen some crazy things oh
i've seen crazy things so tell me tell
me one of your crazy stories
i've seen uh let me tell you the wildest
crazy thing i ever seen you know
i think i've seen somebody you know uh
i've seen gorilla pimps you know i'm
gonna keep it real i've seen gorilla
pimps
you know and i you know when i try and
step up you know since i'm the elder and
the og in the game
and i mention something to them you know
they tell me to stay at their game you
know i've seen a man
uh uh try and drown the chick before
i've seen a
you know i have to really step in and
then they say i'm captain save a hole no
[ __ ] i saved you because you would have
got a life
and you wouldn't be around right now and
he really thanks me for that right
now every time i see a man remember that
man i didn't know what i was doing i was
trying to drown that chicken
you stopped me uh yeah mm-hmm
so things like that they do happen in
the world man
what are you proudest of in your life
what am i proud of
i'm proud of my achievement i'm proud to
be here on earth you know from the grace
of god you know
he's first uh from everything you know
but i'm glad that
my achievements you know i own my own
company i don't have to pimp no mo i
don't have to
uh be mistreated you know i have my own
everything i have my own crib my own
company
you know and i'm functioning well legit
money
there's nothing like legit money you
know you don't have to do it but you
still do
well i have a lot of girls to help me
now you know ain't gonna turn down no
money because i deserve it
you know by being in the game so long
you know i mean
yeah and the game has changed a lot the
game's changed so much man
yeah in what ways has it changed it's
changed you know it's changed like uh
monty hall let's make a deal you know a
lot of pimps you know they just uh
just want to say they have a girl you
understand but you know
they don't have no they stand with their
sister their cousin or something you
know
when you got girls it shows because they
you go to live like a king
and that's what i do live like a king
you know
you been in love before absolutely
yeah that's how i learned from the burns
you know that's what i call messing with
a chick you like
[Laughter]
yeah i better love before man and when
you're in love you know it's unlimited
to what you do for your
you know your spots that you're with you
know and a lot of times you do things
which is
unforbidden to the game you know what i
mean
that that that you notice going it'll
cross you out the game you'll be out the
game quicker than you came in the game
so you got to be careful watch yourself
but that's what happened when you fall
in love but now i'm in love with money
and success in life and of course the
man upstairs
so religion is important to you yeah man
i believe in god man i never would be
you know uh this age had been so many
places to have so much knowledge in his
brain
you know if i didn't believe in god god
saves me
and what what personality trait do you
possess
that helps you do this just be me your
charm
yeah just be me you know but i've
noticed throughout the lifetime you know
really in these last uh 10-15 years the
world is changing
you know sometimes you do stuff for
somebody you know
that's unworthy of it you know what i
mean and
and that's what it is you know you got
to mess with loyal people because one
wrong person
you know it's a lot of haters out there
now a lot of people don't like the game
they don't like you they might have had
a sister
or a brother maybe a mother that
somebody had that claim of pimp and he
was miss pimping
you know and beating on her and put a
scar on and stuff so therefore the son
don't like no pimp you ever see
you know what i mean it's a problem so
you got to keep it on the down low you
know
i don't use your name i don't pimp no
more
but i know the game very well it could
come out every time at any time with
olympia speed
what do you think most squares don't
understand about the game you know
because
a lot of a lot of people make
assumptions well you know a lot of them
you know they just appear you know
uh they they i tell them hate the game
don't hate the player
because you know i'm telling you because
a lot of them just don't like it
and that's the simple reason why they
didn't have a sister or brother or
something
and somebody maybe took advantage of
them you know probably wouldn't even
appear in the whole thing but you know
the drugs is so cold out here in this
world now
you know you have everybody and you know
uh they might not want to admit it but
they got people in that family that do
this and do that and do this you know
what i mean
and they're just not the same you don't
even know who they is anymore
have you ever met anybody and you just
don't know who they is anymore
you know them all the your whole life
and now all of a sudden you
they didn't became to you don't even
know who they are anymore
that happens yeah drugs are a real
problem
yeah everybody have family members like
that man and she said they were used to
be good as gold
they used to have good jobs and all that
and all of a sudden
you see them a year or two later and
then and they're smoking somewhere
they're standing in a doorway with
shoelaces
smoking just a whole different person
the drug game's cold jack you know i
only drink champagne and smoke weeds you
know
i might drink a beer every now and then
but uh you can't drink and think too
and you have to stay thinking your brain
is this is a computer here
a lot of knowledge they call it ism in
the pimp game
all right johnny thank you so much for
sharing your story absolutely
i wish you the best of luck and god
bless you man
church on the move let us pray pimp
johnny dollar international excalibur
atlanta georgia